it'll be a busy morning for workers rep
Philomena Karen buff the union has
called warning strikes to push for a
five and a half percent pay increase
vehicle we need this five and a half
percent what's a production workers
average wage on the production lines
about 1700 years a month before tax home
based in southwest Germany produces
parts for the automotive industry items
such as cup holders three years ago the
company went bankrupt and was bought by
an investment group that's put
management in no mood for a pay hike I
think of what they five and a half
percent is definitely too much last year
we have a 4.3 % rates that on the five
point five percent total almost ten
percent we definitely can't manage that
as an auto parts supplier the works
council takes a different view it's told
production staff to put down their tools
and most have done so four out of five
workers here are union members so what
to employees expect from the pay talks
oh look I'm innocent at least a hundred
euros or more home isn't the only German
company hit by industrial action across
the country more than 40,000 members of
the metal workers union have gone on
strike but are substantially higher pay
rates in industry sustainable we asked
an economist at the university of
stuttgart thank you son i think they are
in the past we've seen that they can
trigger further increases in
productivity but that has broad benefits
Germany can only stay competitive in the
long term when we continue to innovate
and ben de novo gon scuffed steam many
firms are seeking an alternative path
the family owned business Nikolai
produces cables for medical equipment
it's a labor-intensive process so to
keep wage costs down the company built a
plant in Romania the only question now
is how much production to shift their of
Jesus little bit so we're at the point
that we can also make this product in
Romania except for the silicon
processing perhaps the injection molding
and insertion technology minion really
see how much cheaper Romanian workers
more or less fatigue Marty calculating
by the wage cost index it's five times
cheaper or more Oh felts Conan's a taken
the same products for a fraction of the
cost outsourcing to Romania poses a
direct threat to german workers the
works council that Nikolai has also
called warning strikes they say industry
can afford to pay more remember the
community if you look at the profits
that went to employers last year about
50 billion euros then our five and a
half percent is only twenty percent of
them that's a fair share take the
oomphel title yeah baby
both sides will try to hammer out a pay
deal this week